going back to uh sexy pictures on your
Instagram uh there's a video of you from
the early days of Amazon um giving a
tour of your quote sort of offices I
think your dad is holding the camera he
is yeah I know right yes this is what
the Giant Orange extension cord yeah and
you're like explaining the The Genius of
the extension cord how this is there a
desk and the CRT Monitor and sort of
that's where the that's where all the
magic happens get what your dad said but
this is like the the the center of it
all so um what was it like what was
going through your mind at that time you
left a good job in New York and took
this leap were you excited were you
scared so excited and scared anxious you
know thought the odds of success were
low told all of our early investors that
I thought there was a 30% chance of
success by which I just been getting
your money back not like turn not what
actually happened
because that's the truth every startup
company is unlikely to work it's helpful
to be in reality about that um but that
doesn't mean you can't be optimistic so
you kind of have to have this duality in
your head like you on the one hand
you're you know what the Baseline
statistics say about startup companies
and the other hand you have to ignore
all of that and just be 100% sure it's
going to work and you're doing both
things at the same time you're holding
that contradiction in your head but it
was so so exciting I love you know every
from 1994 when uh the company was
founded 1995 when we opened our
doors all the way until today it's I
find Amazon so exciting and that doesn't
mean it's like full of pain full of
problems you know it's like there's so
many things that need to be resolved and
worked and made better and and Etc but
but on balance it's so fun it's such a
privilege it's been such a joy I feel so
grateful that I've been part of that
Journey um it's just been incredible so
in some sense you don't want a a single
day of comfort you've written about this
many times we'll talk about your writing
which uh I I would highly recommend
people read in just the letters to
shareholders uh so you wrote up uh
explaining the idea of day one thinking
I think you first wrote about it 97
letters to shareholders then you also in
a way wrote it
about sad to say is your last letter to
shareholders Co um and you said that day
two is stasis followed by
irrelevance followed by excruciating
painful decline followed by death and
that is why it's always day
one um can you explain this day one
thing this is a really powerful way to
describe the beginning and the journey
of Amazon it's it's really a very simple
and I think age old idea about renewal
and rebirth and like every day is day
one every day you're deciding what
you're going to do and you are not
trapped by what you were or who you were
or any self-consistency self-consistency
even can be a trap
and so day one thinking is kind of we
start fresh every day and we get to make
new decisions every day about invention
about customers about uh how we're going
to operate what our even even even as
deeply as what our principles are we can
go back to that turns out we don't
change those very often but we change
them
occasionally and um when we work on
programs that
Amazon we often uh make a list of
tenants and this the tenants are kind of
they're not principles they're a little
more tactical than principles but it's
kind of the the main ideas that we want
this program to embody whatever those
are and one of the things that we do is
we put these are the tenants for this
program and in parentheses we always put
unless you know A Better Way
MH and and that idea unless you know a
better way is so important because you
never want to get trapped by Dogma you
never want to get trapped by history it
doesn't mean you discard history or
ignore it there's so much value in what
has worked in the past and but you can't
be blindly following what you've done
and that's the heart of day one is
you're always starting fresh and uh to
the question of how to fend off day two
you said such a question can't have a
simple answer as you're saying there
will be many elements multiple paths and
many traps I don't know the whole answer
but I may know bits of it here's a
starter pack of Essentials maybe others
come to mind for day one
defense customer Obsession uh a
skeptical view of proxies the eager
adoption of external trends and high
velocity decision- making so we talked
about High Velocity decision making
that's more difficult than it
sounds so maybe you can pick one that
stands out to you as you can comment on
uh eager adoption of external trends
High Velocity decision-making skeptical
view of proxies how do you fight off day
two well you know I'll talk about
because I think it's the one that is
maybe in some ways the hardest to
understand um is the skeptical view of
proxies um one of the things that
happens in business probably anything
that you're where you're you know you
have an ongoing program and something is
is underway for a number of years is you
develop certain things that you're
managing to like let's say the typical
case would be a
metric and that metric isn't the real
underlying
thing and so uh you know maybe the
metric is um efficiency metric around
customer contacts per unit sold or
something like if you sell
a million units how many customer
contacts do you get or how many returns
do you get and so on and so on and so
what happens is a little bit of a kind
of inertia sets
in where somebody a long time ago
invented that metric and they invented
that metric they decided we need to
watch for you know customer returns per
unit sold as an important metric but
they had a reason why they chose that
metric metric the person who invented
that metric and decided it was worth
watching and then fast forward five
years that metric is the proxy MH the
proxy for truth I guess the proxy for
truth the proxy for custom let's say in
this case it's a proxy for customer
happiness and but that metric is not
actually customer happiness it's a proxy
for customer happiness the person who
invented the metric understood that
connection five years
later
it a kind of inertia can set in and you
forget the truth behind why you were
watching that metric in the first place
and the world shifts a little yeah and
now that proxy isn't as valuable as it
used to be or it's missing something and
you have to be on alert for that you
have to know okay this is I don't really
care about this metric I care about
customer
happiness and this metric is worth
putting energy into and following and
improving and scrutinizing only in so
much as it actually affects customer
happiness and so you got to constantly
be on guard and it's very very common
this is a nuanced problem it's very
common especially in large companies
that they are managing to metrics that
they don't really understand they don't
really know why they exist and the world
may have shifted out from under them a
little in the Met are no longer as
relevant as they were when somebody 10
years earlier invented the metric that
is a Nuance but uh that's a big problem
right there's something so compelling to
have a nice metric to try to optimize
yes and by the way you do need metrics
yes you do you know you can't ignore
them um you want them but you just have
to be constantly on guard this is you
know a a way to slip into day two
thinking would be to manage your
business to metrics that you don't
really understand and you're not really
sure why they were invented in the first
place and you're not sure they're still
as relevant as they used to be uh what
does it take to be the guy or gal who
who uh who brings up the point that this
proxy might be outdated I guess what
does it take to have a culture that
enables that in the meeting CU that's a
very uncomfortable thing to bring up at
a meeting we all showed up here Friday
this is such you have just asked a
million dollar question so th this is
this is what you're if I generalize what
you're asking you talking in general
about
truthtellah you can survive you can
procreate if you're the village truth
teller you might get clubbed to death in
the middle of the night truths are often
they don't want to be heard because
important truths can be um uncomfortable
they can be awkward they can be
exhausting impolite all that kind of
stuff challenging uh they can make
people defensive even if that's not the
intent but any High performing
organization whether it's a sports team
a business you know a political
organization an activist group I don't
care what it is any High performing
organization has to have mechanisms and
a culture that supports
truthtable um you to literally tell
people it's not what we're designed to
do as humans it's not really it's kind
of a side effect you know we can do that
but it's not how we survive we mostly
Survive by being social animals um and
being cordial and cooperative and um
that's really important and so there's a
you know science is all about truth
telling it's actually a very formal
mechanism for trying to tell the truth
and even in science you find that it's
hard to tell the truth right H even you
know you're supposed to have a
hypothesis and test it and find data and
reject the hypothesis and so on it's not
easy but even in science there's like
the senior scientists and the junior
scientists and then there's a hierarchy
of humans where the Som seniority someh
senority matters in the scientific
process which is and that's true inside
companies too and so you want to set up
your culture so that the most Junior
person can overrule the most senior
person if they have data um and and and
that really is about trying to you know
there are little things you can do so
for example in every meeting that I
attend I always speak
last and I know from
experience that you know
if I speak first even
very strong
willed um highly intelligent High
judgment participants in that meeting
will wonder well if Jeff thinks that I
came in this meeting thinking one thing
but maybe I'm not right and so you can
do little things like if you're the most
senior person in the
room go last but let everybody else go
first in fact ideally try to have the
most Junior person go first and the
second then try to go in order of
seniority um so that you can hear
everyone's opinion in a kind of
unfiltered way because we really do we
actually literally change our opinions
if somebody who you really respect says
something makes you change your mind a
little so you're saying implicitly or
explicitly give permission
for people to have a strong opinion that
as long as it's backed by data yes and
sometimes it can even by the way a lot
of our most powerful truths turn out to
be hunches they turn out to be based on
anecdotes they're intuition based and
sometimes you don't even have strong
data but you may know you may know the
person well enough to trust their
judgment you may feel yourself leaning
in it may resonate with a set of
anecdotes you have and then you may be
able to say you know I something about
that feels right let's go collect some
data on that let's try to see if we can
actually know whether it's right but for
now let's not disregard it because it
feels right you can also fight inherent
bias there's an optimism bias like if
there are two interpretations of a new
set of data and one of them is happy and
one of them is
unhappy it's a little dangerous to jump
to the conclusion that the happy
interpretation is
you may want to sort of compensate for
that human bias of of looking for you
know trying to find the silver lining
and said look this that might be good
but I'm going to go with it's bad for
now until we're sure So speaking of
Happiness bias data collection and
anecdotes you have to how's that for a
transition you have to you have to tell
uh me the story of the the call you made
the customer service call you made to
demonstrate a point um about weight
times yeah this is very early in the
history of Amazon and uh we were going
over a weekly Business review and a set
of documents and I have I have a saying
which is when the data and the anecdotes
disagree the anecdotes are usually right
and and it doesn't mean you just
slavishly go follow the anecdotes then
it means you go examine the data because
the and it's usually not the data is
being um misc collected it's usually
that you're not measuring the right
thing and so you know if you have a
bunch of customers complaining about
something and at the same time you know
your metrics look like why are they
shouldn't be complaining um you should
doubt the metrics and an early uh
example of this was we had metrics that
showed that our customers were waiting I
think less than I don't know 60 seconds
when they called a800 number to get you
know phone customer service the wait
time was supposed to be less than 60
seconds and but we had a lot of
complaints that it was longer than that
and anecdotally it seemed longer than
that like you know I would call customer
service myself and so one day we're in a
meeting we're going through the wbr and
the weekly Business review and we get to
this metric in the deck and the guy who
leads customer service is to fit in the
metric and I said okay let's
call and I picked up the phone and I
dialed the 1800 number and called
customer service and we just waited in
silence what did it turn out to be like
oh it was really long more than 10
minutes I think oh wow I mean it was it
was many minutes and so you know it
dramatically made the point that
something was wrong with the data
collection we weren't measuring the
right thing and and that you know set
off a whole chain of events where we
started measuring it right and that's an
example by the way of of Truth telling
is like that's an uncomfortable thing to
do yeah but it's but you have to seek
truth even when it's uncomfortable and
you have to get people's attention and
they have to buy into it and they have
to get energized around really fixing
things so that that speaks to the the
obsession with the customer experience
so one of the defining aspects of your
approach to Amazon is just being
obsessed with making customers happy I
think uh companies sometimes say that
but Amazon is really obsessed with that
I think there's something really
profound to that which is seeing the
world to the eyes of the customer like
the customer experience the human being
that's using the product that's uh
enjoying the product like what they're
like the subtle little
things um that make up their EXP
experience like how do you optimize
those this is another um really good and
kind of deep question because there are
big things that are really important to
manage and then there are small things
in internally to Amazon we call them
paper
cuts so we have we're always working on
the big things like if you ask me and
and most of the energy goes into the big
things as it should so um and you can
identify the big things and I would
encourage anybody if any you knowbody
listening to this is a
entrepreneur as a small business
whatever um you know think about the
things that are not going to change over
10 years and those are probably the big
things so like I know at in our retail
business at Amazon 10 years from now
customers are still going to want low
prices I know they're still going to
want fast delivery and I just know
they're still going to want big
selection so it's impossible to imagine
imagine a scenario where 10 years from
now I say where customer says I love
Amazon I just wish the prices were a
little higher or I love Amazon I just
wish you delivered a little more slowly
so when you identify the big things you
can tell they're worth putting energy
into because they're stable in time okay
but you're asking about something a
little different which is in every
customer experience there are those big
things and by the way it's astonishly
hard to focus even on just the big
things so even though they're obvious
they're really hard to focus on but in
addition to that there are all these
little tiny customer experience
deficiencies and we call those paper
cuts and we make long lists of them and
then we have dedicated
teams that go fix paper cuts because the
teams working on the big issues never
get to the paper
cuts they never work their way down the
the list to get to they're working on
big things as they should and as you
want them to um and so you need special
teams who are charged with fixing paper
cuts where would you put on the on the
paper cut Spectrum the buy now with one
click button which is I think pretty
genius so to me like okay my interaction
with things I love on the internet
there's things I do a lot I maybe
representing regular human uh I would
love for those things to be frictionless
for example uh booking airline
tickets just saying but you know
it's buying a thing with one click
making that experience frictionless
intuitive all aspects of that like that
that just fundamentally makes my life
better not just in terms of efficiency
in terms of some kind of cognitive load
yeah cognitive load and PE inner peace
and happiness first of all buying
stuff uh isn't a pleasant experience H
having enough money to buy a thing and
then buying it is a pleasant experience
and like having pain around that is
somehow just you're ruining a be a
beautiful experience and I guess all I'm
saying as a as a person who loves good
ideas is that a paper cut a solution to
a paper cut yes so it's probably that
particular thing is probably a solution
to a number of paper cuts so if you go
back and look at our order Pipeline and
how people shopped on Amazon before we
invented oneclick shopping there were a
whole Ser there was more friction there
was a whole series of paper cuts and
that uh invention eliminated a bunch of
paper cuts and I think you're absolutely
right by the way that there when you
come up with something like oneclick
shopping again this is like so ingrained
in people now I'm impressed that you
even notice it I mean most people every
time I click the button most people
surge of Happiness this there is in in
the perfect invention for the perfect
moment in the perfect context there is
real Beauty yeah it is actual Beauty and
it feels good it's emotional it's
emotional for the inventor it's
emotional for the team that builds it
it's emotional for the customer it's a
big deal and you can feel those things
but to keep coming up with that idea
with those kinds of ideas I guess is the
the day one thinking effort yeah and you
need you need a big group of people who
feel that kind of uh satisfaction with
creating that kind of
beauty